et une réunion d'urgence est prévue ce
soir un sommet à bruxelles les
dirigeants européens vont faire le point
emmanuel macron appelle les européens à
l'unité le chef de la diplomatie joseph
bourrel affirme que la russie devra
faire face à un isolement sans précédent
pierre bénazet bonjour ça veut dire donc
plus de sanctions
que depuis plusieurs semaines déjà les
européens ont commencé à préparer ces
sanctions on a vu les premières qui ont
été déclenchées après la reconnaissance
de law and three donetsk c'était
seulement une première vague on le
savait déjà depuis ce matin l'union
européenne affirme qu'elle va déclencher
des sanctions massives qui doivent faire
mal à la russie c'est ce que disait
d'ailleurs josep borrell lui-même quand
il s'est exprimé ce matin aux côtés de
ours ou la fender 'lion' la présidente
de la commission on l'a revue elle
d'ailleurs à l'instant elle parlait il
ya une petite heure aux côtés de jens
stoltenberg le secrétaire général de
l'otan et de charles michel le président
du conseil européen les européens
essayent de trouver aussi des outils
politiques et ils se coordonnent donc
avec l'otan en ville et puis aussi avec
leurs partenaires du g7 avec qui ils
sont en visio conservant en
visioconférence il ya donc cette
conférence ce sommet européen ce soir à
partir de 20h heure de bruxelles où ces
sanctions massives seront décidées elles
ont été approuvées à priori formulée en
tout cas peaufiner ce matin par les
vingt-sept ambassadeur représentant
permanent dans le sort au sein du
coreper qui est la plus haute instance
permanente ici des vingt-sept des
sanctions avant tout économiques qui
doivent couper la russie du reste de
l'europe la coupe et des marchés
financiers
peut-être même c'est ce que réclament
les baltes en tout cas la coupe et de
swift la chambre de compensation
financière internationale qui
interrompraient donc toute transaction
financière pour la russie bref des
sanctions économiques qui doivent aussi
touché les outils d'avenir les
technologies d'avenir c'est ce que
disait ursula von der leyen
emmanuel macron appel à l'unité on peut
dire qu'il y a
unité que les vingt-sept parle d'une
seule voix sur cette question même le
hongrois
ban a condamné cette invasion russe oui
effectivement et c'est un point très
important particulièrement pour la
hongrie car comme la slovaquie la
pologne ou la roumanie elle a une
frontière commune avec l'ukraine et elle
se tient au goûter de l'ukraine comme
tous les autres européens il y avait eu
des rumeurs lors de la décision du
premier train de sanctions disant que la
roumanie que la hongrie n'était pas
entièrement d'accord avec les autres
c'était faux les hongrois ont tenu à le
faire savoir dans les minutes qui ont
suivi la première apparition de ces
rumeurs les hongrois comme tous leurs
partenaires européens sont entièrement
du côté de l'ukraine ils veulent que la
russie paye un prix politique quelles
que soient les liens entre viktor orban
et vladimir poutine la hongrie comme
tous les autres européens estiment que
cette attaque contre le créditent d'une
attaque contre l'europe et donc contre
l'union européenne il ya donc une vraie
université des européens aujourd'hui ils
veulent avoir une vraie voix unique et
c'est la raison pour laquelle aussi il
en parle avec le temps et il y aura
aussi un sommet de l'otan un sommet de
l'otan virtuel demain normalement les
européens auront une seule voix une
seule attitude face à moscou c'est là le
plus grave événement depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale selon les propos mêmes
de josep borrell sur les sanctions
pierre donc on attend ce sommet européen
ce soir on imagine que les européens
pèse le pour et le contre puisque
économiquement on pourrait être les
grands perdants de la situation et de
ces sanctions et un effet boomerang là
que les européens ne néglige pas alors
c'est vrai il ya un premier effet qui
est celui des contres sanctions dont
vladimir poutine menace déjà les
européens on sait qu' il y avait déjà eu
des mesures de rétorsion après les
sanctions suite à l'invasion de
l'ukraine elles ont coûté cher des
entreprises européennes en particulier à
des agriculteurs français par exemple il
y aura aussi le coût de
l'approvisionnement
le coût de l'approvisionnement en gaz et
la bourse ou la von der leyen promet des
sources d'approvisionnement alternatives
mais elles sont pas encore sur la table
avec la norvège avec le canada par
exemple pour des terminaux pétroliers en
pologne et puis il y aura aussi
évidemment le coût pour l'importation
des céréales les états membres ont
essayé de peser le pour et le contre de
faire en sorte que c'est charges soient
équilibrés pour chacun mais il n'y a pas
de garantie que ça coûte pas
excessivement cher à l'union européenne
merci beaucoup pierre bénazet et donc à
ce soir